ارتفعت اسعاره نفس اليوم مسجله اكبر زياده
يوميه منذ نحو عام بعد اعلان دول تخفيضات
في الانتاج بشكل غير متوقع وارتفع خامو
برنت اثناء التداولات بنحو سته في المئه
مقتربا من نحو 85 دولارا للبرميل كما
ارتفع
الى ما يقارب 80 دولارا للبرميل ومنذ
تشرين الثاني نوفمبر الماضي بلغ اجمالي
تخفيضات الانتاج لدول اوبك بلاس نحو ثلاثه
ملايين الف برميل يوميا تعادل اكثر من
ثلاثه في المئه من الطلب العالمي على
النفط
وقالت لجنه المتابعه الوزاريه المشتركه
لدول اوبك بلاسا اليوم ان حجم تخفيض
الطوعي لانتاج النفط سيكون مليونا
و660 الف برميل يوميا واضافت اللجنه بعد
اجتماعها الذي جاء عقب اعلان خفض الانتاج
ان هذا الاجراء احترازي ويهدف الى دعم
استقرار السوق النفطيه وجاء اجتماع اللجنه
تمهيدا لرفع توصيتها الى الاجتماع الموسع
المزمع عقده في يونيو حزيران القادم بمقر
المنظمه للدول الثلاث والعشرين الاعضاء
المنتجه للنفط من داخل وخارجي اوبك
وقال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكسندر
نوفاك ان روسيا ستمدد تخفيض انتاجها
النفطي بواقع نصف مليون برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام وقال نوفاك ان هذا التخفيض هو
اجراء احترازي للتحوط من مزيد من تقلبات
السوق وبذلك تمدد روسيا تخفيض انتاجها من
النفط للمره الثانيه بعد التمديد الاول
الذي اعلنه نوفاك في فبراير شباط الماضي
في المقابل قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي انه لا يعتقد
ان تخفيضات منطقيه في هذا التوقيت نظرا
لعدم اليقين في السوق اضاف كيربيانا اداره
بايدن تركز على خفض الاسعار
للمستهلكين الامريكيين وشدد على ان
الاداره ستواصل العمل مع جميع المنتجين
والمستهلكين لضمان ان تدعم سوق النفط
النمو سوق النفط النمو الاقتصاديه وانخفاض
الاسعار للمستهلكين الامريكيين
مراسل الجزيره نور الدين بوزيان نور الدين
اهلا بك خلفيه اتخاذ لهذا القرار في هذا
التوقيت ثم الا توجد هناك اتفاقات بخصوص
مواعيد
لتخفيض الانتاج يعني في اي سياق جاء هذا
التخفيض
سياقات كثيره مريم لعل ابرزها ربما كما
يقول الذين ينتمون الى
ربما الخوف من خضات وهزات جيو سياسيه في
اشاره الى الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه هناك
ايضا معطيات اقتصاديه ومؤشرات اقتصاديه
دعيني اتوقف مثلا عند الصين تعرفين جيدا
انه عندما صدر التقرير قبل التقرير الماضي
لدول اوبك كان يتحدث عن ان الصين مثلا
احتوت بشكل كبير تداعيات كورونا وان
اقتصادها بدا يقلع من جديد لكن المؤشرات
التي ظهرت في ايام القليله الماضيه تؤكد
بان الارقام الاقتصاديه الصينيه لا تبعث
على التفاعل وهذا ربما احد العوامل
باعتبار ان الصين زبون كبير لدول الاوبك
بلاس احد العوامل الذي يكون دفع بدول اوبك
وخاصه الدول الرئيسيه فيها الى خفض انت من
مايو المقبل حتى نهايه السنه الجاريه ربما
المفارقه مريم هو ان الاجتماع الذي عقد
اليوم كان في فتره ماضيه قال بانه يجب ان
نلتزم ونمتثل للقرارات التي اتخذت في
اكتوبر عام 2022 وهي الالتزام فقط بخفض
مليوني برميل يوميا اما الان اذا اضفتي
الخفض السنه الماضيه زائد هذه المره القفض
واحد فاصل 66
الف
مليون برميل و660 الف يعني هذا يؤكد بان
الحجم كبير وهذا هي ربما من هنا جاءت
المفاجاه المفاجاه الاخرى لماذا مثلا لم
يتخذ او تتخذ دول اوبيك بلاس القرار داخل
الاجتماعي لوزراء الخارجيه واتخذ طوعيا
البعض يقول ربما ان دول اوبك حاولت ان
تبقي عن تماسكها لانها كانت تخشى لو طرحت
هذه المساله مساله خفض الانتاج ربما
سيتسبب في بعض الهزات داخل اوبك باعتبار
ان بعض الدول الصغيره التي لا تنتج كثيرا
ربما تحتاج الى اموال وبالتالي من الصعب
ان تطلب منها الدول الكبرى ان تخفض
انتاجها الان السؤال كيف ستواجه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا القرار علما بان
هناك بدايه ازمه كانت ظهرت في اجتماع
اكتوبر الماضي ولكن على ما يبدو الولايات
المتحده ستلجا الى خيارات اخرى ومن بين
الخيارات الابقاء على قناه الاتصال مع
الاوبك وهذا الذي ورد في تصريحات احد
المسؤولين الامريكيين مريم
شكرا جزيلا لك